welcome to james kennedy joining me uh
to talk about his recent novel dare to
know um beautiful oh you've got a copy
too not a big surprise right
so you know um
i've got a number of questions for you
but i also know from our previous
conversation that you can easily riff
off of all sorts of stuff and i think
that's also there in the writing itself
but i i think we have to begin
since people haven't read the book most
likely before they get here although you
may have a few fans of the book popping
in that have seen it
tell us what the book is i mean this
dare to know dare to know what
okay so uh dare to know is about this uh
down and out salesman who works for a
company also called dare to know that
can calculate the exact time of your
death
um there's just one rule you're not
allowed to look up your own uh time of
death uh but late one night and the main
character is a salesman for this company
and late one night feeling desperate for
many reasons this salesman uh breaks
that rule and he looks himself up and he
discovers that he had died
23 minutes ago
um but the algorithm is never wrong um
but he's still alive so what's going on
um and uh this sets him on a journey
across the country and through his own
memories uh to confront the decisions of
his life um to solve the mystery of why
the seemingly infallible math fails only
for him
so
that happens if i remember correctly
about maybe a third of the way into the
story there's a lot of
narrative scene setting that's taking
place you meant you mentioned memory and
there's there's a ton of like him
reminiscing about his
childhood adolescence teenage years
college years working for dare to know
how does that lead into this this moment
you said that he's kind of down and out
and i mean that's a good way to describe
it the very the book begins i have death
in my pocket folded up ready to go
ordinarily i wouldn't take on a client
like this but i have to make this sale
yeah my uh at one point i i jokingly
said to my editor can we call this book
salesman of a
with this kind death
like
willie lowman-esque like main character
it's kind of glenn gary glenn ross kind
of like uh downtrouting guy yeah i mean
i figured like if you're going to have
us
a science fiction story about
uh and it's going to be emotionally
resonant about the time of your death
what's
it's interesting what happens after you
die and the book touches on that but
what's really interesting is what kind
of life did you live it kind of like
sets into
the perspective like what all the
decisions that i made along this way uh
what did it all mean and how does it all
come together and how did it all lead to
this and that's why um
in his he in the book he has to seek out
his old flame julia the kind of one he
loved and lost on the way through his
life because she's the only one who can
uh for various reasons confirm that his
calculation was correct um and that kind
of um
and the book is marketed as a thriller
and in some ways it is but it's maybe
more of a philosophical thriller which
is why it's appropriate that we're on
this podcast
and a lot of like working through ideas
in it about like haunted video games
this occult alternative you know history
of science the dark side of startup
culture the ancient native american city
of cahokia conspiracy theories about top
40 music and plato's cave and other
stuff yeah
yeah so there's a lot of moving parts
that you just mentioned right there and
i think
you could explain them but i think for
somebody who hasn't read the book
how they're connected together is not
going to coalesce right but they do in
fact all these these things
it's not as if they're moving parts
really they're all like different
perspectives on the same
fundamental
reality so there's a metaphysics
involved here you mentioned plato's cave
and
there is a discussion about plato's cave
in there i think that might be something
that that a lot of people can relate to
because they've at least heard of that
right so yeah
you have a different take on plato's
cave
embedded in there what what is it
yeah so um
the
in the book so uh this uh kind of
obnoxious guy corners our hero at a
party and starts explaining plato's cave
to him which is like the only way you
can get away with explaining something
philosophically in the novel is you have
an obnoxious person do it and the other
person is like i can't wait to get out
of this discussion which is a way for
and i say this as somebody who loves
philosophy and with a philosophy you
know double major in college physics and
philosophy however i know that people's
americans
patience is limited for this kind of
thing and if you could if you could say
like if you could put like the main
character in a kind of a han solo kind
of like i don't believe in any of this
stuff like what are you going to get to
the point then you're kind of indicating
to the reader yeah don't worry it's
going to go somewhere but um the uh yeah
so the this person is explaining plato's
cave but he's talking about this friend
of his who's writing a children's book
about basically the premise of like and
quickly plato's cave is you've got all
these people they're sitting
your viewers all know plato's game i
don't have to well i mean yeah i mean
what are the what are the absolutely key
elements in your view right so there's a
bunch of uh people they're trapped in a
cave they can't move they're looking at
these shadows on the wall they think
that those shadows are the realities of
the world like a shadow of a horse a
shadow of a tree whatever but these
shadows which they sit and look at and
say oh that's reality are actually just
the shadows of puppets that are being
moved in the back of the cave past this
fire but the people never see these
these puppets move or the people moving
them and then plato says what if
somebody got out and you know saw
reality and came back and said look i
saw a real horse i saw a real tree said
no you're crazy these shadows are what's
real and so the the take in the book is
like what if
the main character of that
parable isn't the people in the cave or
even the person who got out but the
shadows
because these poor shadows they want to
be real they uh they the shadow of a
horse wants to be a horse the shadow of
a tree wants to be a tree and it's a
heroic the idea if they could escape the
cave and become real and in dare to know
we kind of get this understanding that
the world that we're in is
it is just this world of shadows and the
fundamental action that the hero does in
the end allows these shadows to escape
the cave and become realities um in this
next universe to come spoiler
i like that that formulation though that
the shadows want to be real you know
it's almost like pinocchio wanting to be
a real boy except pinocchio has a frame
of reference right he sees real boys all
over the place and he's like there's
something wrong with me
right but in plato's cave there that's
part of the problem is the the prisoners
and you know by extension the shadows
would have no
alternative frame of reference but
you've got
frames of reference like bursting
through right
uh yeah the metaphysical go ahead well i
mean a novelist like takes philosophical
problems and like just mines them for
drama like not caring
you know
what what it actually you know means
because when i when i like because it
goes
who is it i think it's
is it heidegger who talks about like we
walk around we know that we don't have
any being
right or or who's a philosopher or john
paul
sorry okay that's it yeah
we know that we don't have any being we
look around we see other people they
seem to have intentions and wants and
desires they seem to know who they are
and what they want and so we look at
them and say oh i wish i was real like
them i mean it's a very relatable thing
uh to know that you in in your heart of
hearts are a nullity but everybody else
seems to be real so i think it's yeah
it's a relatable perspective to take
when we realize for sartre
that other people are like us that they
aren't like fixed in stone they aren't
just
objects that we can constantly rely upon
it's interesting because for start that
winds up being scary and threatening he
talks about the
realization that like another person is
at the other end of a field and then
he frames it in these very spatial
metaphors like all the meaning is being
sucked towards that other person like
they're
a hole in existence and then you know
there's other existentialists who have
let's call it just happier you know
viewpoints like you know we can realize
the other person is free and then
therefore love them or be in a
relationship with them
so i mean if we if you view those as
kind of polarities
you know you mentioned julia who
i guess you know you could say this is
the girlfriend of the of the main
character right
yeah
can you say that she's like the second
main character in the
work there's precious few characters in
the book yeah i think it's like her and
him um and you know maybe three or four
other people um it's a pretty lonely
book
um
yeah that's a good way to describe it um
there is a lot of loneliness built into
it i mean he's got a former wife and
kids who he can't really
relate to they're divorced right the
kids um
kind of view him as a script dad
yeah
he's got his work colleagues that he
used to be close with but
now um nobody really likes each other
anymore
[Laughter]
and he has a friend um
[Music]
oh yeah bernard bernard yes his
childhood friend yeah
yeah i mean a lot of this is sort of the
soliloquy of uh
a guy on his own engaging that in
actions
um
but doing a lot of thinking about his
own condition isn't it
yeah
actually let me let me bring this back
to the death of a salesman idea because
that was part of the marketing materials
for this it's death of a salesman meets
the matrix and i you know when when i
first got pitched this by the um agent
from cork books i was like ah i don't
know about this you know everybody has
these bombastic kind of um
kind of copy right yes and and it's part
of salesmanship itself to do that so it
was kind of on a metal level and then i
read the book and i was like holy crap
this is this is really awesome thank you
um and
i actually said something
that
um and i did it in social media and you
were very gracious about it i said this
isn't really um
the matrix meets death of a salesman
this is much more like a philip k
dick novel and i used this metaphor
where i said you know black sabbath you
know seminal metal band there's this
other really really great band called
orchid and they were the ones who
created the songs that black sabbath
never produced they're like along the
lines but they're updated and i said
well this is sort of like a philip k
dick novel except written by somebody in
the 21st century
and i was kind of curious you know when
i when i wrote that i was like ah i
wonder if he's not going to like that
because
you know it's saying it's derivative or
something everybody which is not what i
don't know i i i
any author worth their assault would
love to be compared to philip k dick
he's a visionary you know like a lot of
people can write competently but only a
few people are visionaries and and you
know and sometimes he wrote
incompetently he was a visionary that's
true and um
and like like sometimes you know he he's
intolerable but there's some books of
his like like ubik you know and i see
that you're doing a thing on uh on your
channel about do android's dream of
electric sheep um and
like he's worthy of close inspection and
i wanted to write a book that was worthy
of close inspection
oh that's interesting so close
inspection would that mean like you want
readers to
not only pay attention the first read
but like go back and like you know say
what was what was actually happening
here try to piece the thing back
together yeah because i yeah yes like i
mean hopefully
that's the dream right is it the reality
i don't know but i um i
like my favorite things uh like works of
art or like books or movies or whatever
are things that i find myself compelled
to go back to
um because so like something like
there's a
there's a mystery that cannot be
resolved not like i'm going back to
figure it out but i'm going back to go
and sit in the mystery again so like
david lynch makes me feel that way that
you know mulholland drives yeah i can go
you can go online you can go see all the
you know theories about what mulholland
drive really means and or twin peaks or
whatever however what's fun about it
what the thing that makes it worthwhile
is going and just experiencing it being
put in the hands of somebody and sitting
in the mystery that they're giving you
um i took my daughter to see a 2001 a
space odyssey at like the big uh
uh uh music box theater here in uh in
chicago they were um they're doing a 70
millimeter uh like re-showing of it it
was glorious and at the end of it you
know you can kind of have a theory about
what's going on but the fun of it is
that you're sitting in the mystery you
know um and but you can't start out in
the mystery
you have to start like just as twin
peaks starts as a normal police
procedural
and mulholland drive starts with
something normal and you kind of
you boil the frog a little bit and get
more and more intense and weird until at
the end you know you've got dale cooper
sitting in the street at the end of
season three of twin beaks going what
year is it you know and like you don't
know what he means but i'll be thinking
about that you know forever like what
that scene means and when the lights go
out and laura palmer screams
um so that's that's a really interesting
way to put it like a mystery isn't
something that you solve once and for
all like the scooby-doo gang and they
pull the mask off and you know now the
mystery machine can move on to the next
thing it's rather there's a lot of
different aspects and each one
connects up kind of with the others says
something about the others but you're
not
still at the end it you're not quite
sure how things hold together and you
know you brought up dick's android's
dream of electric sheep and you know
i've been reading and rereading it
recently
and some parts of it don't add up yeah
you know and and you don't notice it
until you've read through a couple times
that some of the things that some of the
characters are saying or doing
they don't all fit in
together effectively now
i i mean
is that the case for for dare
for me like i've got a murder board in
which everything makes sense to me
okay um but like
i think for a you know a gestalt you
know to work
it shouldn't all fit together so neatly
on the first read and i think like what
you're trying to do is not so much
be like lost and here's a riddle that
you have to solve but it has to be i'm
going to provide a fertile ground for
interpretation um and and and so i have
my own interpretation of it but i
i've like talked to other people oh i
think this means that i think this means
that and i like that they have a
different idea than me and i wanted to
not create something to be solved but a
fertile ground for interpretation now
does that get you a lot of readers
well
[Laughter]
we are in america
so some readers would perceive that as
too much of a challenge or
too much work being demanded on on their
end right well then in that case they
can just sit back and enjoy the
scintillating prose style
well and the action that's that's taking
place right yes yes or the ideas or the
weird stuff or whatever um but yeah but
for those who i mean i don't i don't
read or watch enough things that kind of
approach mystery in that way and so i
wanted to
give my
contribution to that corpus of mysteries
okay yeah you know and another thing
that
again to go back to the philip k dick uh
resemblance
so
dick
himself has a lot of characters who are
either sales people or or kind of
connected tangentially with sales and
there's a desperation sometimes on their
part that that clearly the main
character of this
feels you know he's working for a
company that used to be like top of the
line and now he's got a you know when
when you have to sell a product if your
product is really good it's super easy
to sell it you just educate people and
they're like yeah i want this but now
he's he's got what seems to be it's not
an inferior product but it's not
providing the same
glitz as the competitors do right
the competitors if i remember right so
they not only tell you
when you're gonna die but they don't do
it with complete accuracy they tell you
how you're going to die yes so but it's
it's kind of like heisenberg's
uncertainty principle the more
accurately you know when you're going to
die the less accurately how um and none
of in eve and they can't even max out at
100 for either of them uh it's like
they're using inferior algorithms but
they're glitzier and more interesting
and i kind of wanted to give that
feeling of like
how the
how the tech industry has changed uh um
and like as a you know a former computer
program or software engineer
like the uh the way that like
inferior products are more popular
sometimes than like bulletproof things
that are um
that are really good um and but just
like the way that they're sold or the
context in which they're given or just
the fact that they're new
um yeah like just like like
why can't you
why can't you put a link in instagram
you know why are you deliberately
crippling your product in that way or
they can for until recently you couldn't
upload to instagram from your computer
you had to go this roundabout way like
why are you deliberately crippling it
why are you making it worse than it
could be um and there's all kinds of
weird marketing reasons or whatever like
no this is we want you to use it in this
way on your phone or not on your
computer however but it's uh
it it i i i it's based a little bit on
that uh um like the uh
just and also the the main character is
company kind of not being what it used
to be the internet is not what it used
to be i think starting around 2012 it
started to feel different to me uh
and that's something that made its way
into the book yeah too yeah um the uh
like
i guess hold on uh
get this out of the way
sorry um
yikes
hold on
yeah yeah so
you can just edit that out
like um so like when i was a kid like i
loved like programming my like trusty
atari 800 like like making games in my
20s like i loved like you know the the
internet felt very like handmade and
just for weirdos uh and then i love
being computer programmer but it was
like computers were about exploration
they're about creativity they're about
liberation you have things like you know
the free software foundation you know
it's like we have like information wants
to be free and everybody's sharing their
creativity for free online and like
working collaborative really on
wikipedia for free
and but now it's become this kind of
cursed realm of grifters kind of
monetizing their connections
and it becomes a zone of like
surveillance and distraction and
propaganda and i felt that started to
happen in 2012 and on the business side
i started watching all these startups
flame out becoming shells of what they
were and i wanted to portray the
emotional feeling of how that felt like
you were working for me that was kind of
like on the cutting edge and now that
moment has passed you by and the
shittier product is the one that does
better now
yeah
i mean it's kind of like an architecture
of cities right you have all these
beautiful
old buildings but you go in and they're
kind of run down and they if they had
enough tlc they could be rehabbed into
something really gorgeous like you know
for example you know the milwaukee
symphony orchestra here in milwaukee we
have this gorgeous new building but it
took an awful lot of work to make it
happen and weirdly enough too
they had to move a wall in order because
it was a historic building they had to
take an entire wall of the building and
move it over something like nine feet or
ten feet and then rebuild the thing
around it didn't that mess up the
acoustics like to move no because what
they did is they they they built an
entire new concert hall within it oh
it's like so this is kind of an
interesting comparison because it's it's
like if you think about it
scientifically it's like the
most up-to-date understanding of
acoustics went into building this with
the materials you know the materials of
today which are all still wood and and
things like that
um and you know 40 years from now it
won't be state of the art it'll be
pretty good yeah but it won't be like
cutting edge or anything like that and
and we've got all these buildings here
in milwaukee you know chicago's like
that as well where they somehow didn't
get torn down because there was a
recession at the time and now we've
we've got to figure out what we're going
to do with them right
and you could say that a lot of
literature is like that you know we
we have all these
books that
you know like when you read philip k
dick right some of the predictions he
made about the future clearly
didn't come off the way they did you
know he didn't he didn't really um
conceptualize the internet for example
right so he has homeopaths you print out
an actual paper that you look at at home
which is kind of like what we do except
we do it on our screens and stuff like
that i mean and and so coming back to
the dick comparison so you're in a
better vantage point in a way to do a
dickensian
type of story because you're writing it
you know
in the in the dick reality
yeah exactly um yeah i mean for philip k
dick i don't know if any science fiction
author or maybe only the most boring
science fiction authors are trying to
predict the future you know in a
technical way maybe like arthur c clarke
you know which okay i love him but you
know kind of a boring guy it's not they
weren't exactly ray bradbury like
famously said like oh no i'm writing to
prevent the future
and and i think that that that's and
like so when philip k dick in ubik
has the guy arguing with his door
because the door won't open to his own
apartment unless he gives it a nickel
like he wants to prevent that fusion
he's not trying to predict that future
he's not going to be happy if he's right
um and uh it's funny the people who
aren't trying to predict the future are
the ones who get it eat like
correct the most often the person who
probably predicted the future the best
was douglas adams the hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy is essentially wikipedia
um
is donald trump somebody who is there
not to wield power but to distract you
from the wielding of power which is how
he describes a5 people brock's in in
hitchhiker's
hitchhiking
there's so many things in it that he
just like said oh this is my little
satirical thing like oh it's my take off
on that you're up on five dollars a day
what about the chicken's guy to the
galaxy but that ended up being true
and i kind of do a riff on douglas adams
in the book although i don't mention him
uh explicitly but i talk about uh
renault like there's this uh
books that the main character likes that
renard who's really into silver age
science fiction doesn't like which is
like this funny englishman who you know
it's oh right yeah and that and and in a
biography written by neil gaiman
actually of douglas adams there is a um
there is notes about hitchcock's guide
to the galaxy book that was not written
which doug which arthur dent the main
character of those books has realizes
he's forgotten something about his life
he needs to but it's something crucial
he needs to know so he decides okay well
i know that when you're about to die
if your life flashes before your eyes so
i'm going to jump off a cliff the life
my life is going to flash before my eyes
and then and then i'll find out this
thing and as for what happens when i hit
the ground well i'll solve that problem
when i come to it um and he never wrote
that book but i referenced that and
dared a note and that is kind of
what dare to know is about it's a guy's
life flashing before his eyes trying to
figure out that one important thing
um
it's kind of funny because you if you
think about
that as a project
so you've got a limited amount of time
right because you've jumped off of a
cliff or something or you injected
yourself with a poison and you need the
antidote and it's sort of the proverbial
drinking from a fire hose you've got all
these memories that you'd be flooded
with how do you sift them to figure out
which is the actual one
that you needed i guess the important
one
i guess the important one is so
important you'll see it you know but you
just need that sudden clarity of seeing
every you know piece at once
yeah um i mean but that's the thing it's
like by joking around by being absurd by
just like doing some just going off for
like for a joke
like i think he would sometimes say
things that were you know deeper than
you know
i don't know william gibson or something
you know uh somebody else who's working
at the same time who's working in a more
self-consciously serious vein
yeah
gibson is a funny one too and i don't
want to take us too off topic with this
but you might have something useful to
riff on this i mean he he predicts the
internet but he gets it very wrong in a
number of different ways and then when
people asked him about it later he's
like well
i didn't spend any time doing internet
stuff i just imagined it myself
you know
he wrote he wrote neuromancer on a
typewriter right you know like
this is not like i mean and also he he
did he did a good like again i don't
think he was trying to be accurate but
what he did do is he made it tolerable
because there's nothing worse than
modern things like modern things about
like if somebody's getting on the
internet in a movie now they're like you
just watch a bunch of people with the
screens glowing in their face and
they're typing and they're saying we're
in right now whereas in neuromancer
they're like they're like these
geometrical beings floating through
space and doing very cinematic things i
mean he made the right choice as a
novelist
um to show what cyberspace looks like
now it got made into a lot of adapted a
lot of terrible 90s movies of people
floating around really cheesy cyberspace
but as for that novel that i mean that
is again visionary yeah um and when i
said williamson before i wasn't trying
to take anything away from him uh um but
i i'm just like i think douglas adams is
sometimes thought of as a jokester but
in fact i think he's the
the futurist
to to rule them all and in the darkness
find them well you know so one of the
questions that i i had lined up is you
know a pretty typical question i'm not
going to ask you the silly one where do
you get your ideas from but something
that's almost as banal as that
so you mentioned a number of authors
who are the people that have
have influenced you or got their hooks
into you
the most i mean there's dick there's you
mentioned adams
gibson
well i guess as far as like science
fiction goes like uh the writers that i
grew up with were like the usual
suspects of like golden age science
fiction um
like asimov ray bradbury uh those are my
big favorites and to a lesser extent
yeah arthur c clarke um i've never cared
for heinlein
um like uh i i
in this but in this i mean for the same
reason i love dick dick has these down
trotting characters you know in highland
all these like super competent engineers
you know that like i just don't vibe
with
um but that okay it says it says more
about me than it says about him let's
say that um but it was pointed out to me
though that one of highland's very
earliest short stories it's called
lifeline okay it's about a guy who
invents a machine that can predict when
you're going to die now i had not read
this before i wrote dare to know but i
did read it after it was pointed out to
me it's a lot more straightforward than
dare to know um but uh yeah so like
those were the biggies but then when i
was in high school like i was um
i was still really into science fiction
and i read orwell's 1984 and huxley's uh
brave new world just because they were
science fiction i thought oh i want to
read more by these great science fiction
authors but of course nothing else
either of them did even remotely science
fiction but then but i got addicted to
it and i read everything i could get on
my hands on by them and anyway and that
was my back door into like proper adult
20th century literature and that like
led me on to other authors and it gave
me a context for understanding them um
and in in college i finally read ulysses
okay uh and that was transformative um
and maybe the stream of consciousness
style of dare to know is probably
influenced by it like the rhythm of the
way that leopold bloom the fragmentary
way that leopold bloom speaks okay uh
his thoughts are kind of like that and i
mean i'm not going to compare myself to
joyce it's super potential but
if you want me to get
my 30s i finally read proof okay and
that was also transformative and freeing
because he showed me that like
successful fiction or the fiction that i
like
could be you don't have to have
traditional scenes like you can just
have elaborately thoughtful ruminations
um that kind of tug at ideas and look at
them from several perspectives and tease
out possibilities and and play out a
metaphor for several pages and and i
tried to do that with dare to know that
kind of like okay i'm going to explore
some ideas here and i'm going to like
look at and it's about memory and
looking back on our life just as you
know famously um
you know proust is you know he he he has
a madeline he
steps down that step you know and those
are the two like moments um and so i
also i was also impressed that proof
throughout 3000 pages from the first
person perspective of somebody whose
name we never learn and i was like that
for some reason is very evocative i want
to do that and so i did that with jared
no we never know the guy's name um
but more recently as far as science
fiction goes um i've been into the short
stories of ted chang oh okay he's
yeah he's a guy wrote the short story
that arrival was based on uh the time of
your life um he often takes you know if
you've read him like a high concept
premise pushes it to the limit but in a
very precise and controlled way
which is the opposite in a way of dick
who just goes past that limit into
something more hallucinatory and trippy
sometimes
and um and so i think jared knows starts
out ted changish and with a little bit
of dick and then gets more and more
dickish as it goes on
and and i wanted like yeah so um but the
tone
of jared and oh more than anything was
influenced by um
there was this book that impressed me in
my twenties by evelyn wa uh called work
suspended
and
yeah and it's um
so you know as we know he made his early
career like writing humorously these
kind of like brittle merciless comic
novels and then and and my first novel
uh it was a young adult fantasy called
the order of odd fish and it has some
intentional tonal similarities to wah's
early stuff kind of like funny but kind
of you know
uh fussy and english and whatever but in
was middle age like but this is before
bright side revisited his style
underwent this big change um and he
wrote this melancholy odd fragment that
got published that says work suspended i
remember being very drawn in by its
confessional nature i was like oh a
novel can just be a confession like it
could have the structure of a confession
um like that's which is different than
like you see structures like oh it's a
hero's journey yeah yeah you know or
it's a rise and fall of something but
here's a different way to structure
something as a confession um and um in
the narrator coming to terms with who he
is it was very middle-aged book like
when life is no longer a matter of like
these big possibilities and it's more
like reckoning with what you've done
your own history and it put death at the
center in a like this calm
non-hysterical way that i found really
engaging and so i read work suspended my
20s and i thought i can't write
something like this but i want i really
admire it and reengaging with that book
in my 40s uh it gave me a secret passage
let me get out of like this kind of
funny stuff i was writing for kids and
for this more humorous register which i
can still do and i still like to do but
but writing from douglas adams dishway a
fantasy into something more somber and
ambitious and dreamlike for adults so
talking about confessions naturally
raises a question that i'm sure other
people have asked you
with this character you know
you've got um you know a person who's
been a salesman somebody who has been a
programmer
uh interested in startup culture all
these these connections to your own life
and you've got you know i i will say
this too as somebody who grew up here in
the 70s and the 80s in the midwest
for me
um there were so many things where i was
like oh yeah i remember that i you know
i didn't play exactly that game but i
remember games like that or i remember
camps like that going off to the you
know um the local college with its kind
of
weird smelling classrooms and things
like that so how i mean
obviously the main character is not you
but how much of you is is in the main
character and his memories and his fears
and desires and things like that
a lot of him is my worst self okay
um like you people have said oh my gosh
it's it's like you know i read like i've
never i read this one review i've never
read a book so quickly or been so
compelled by it and been so repulsed by
the narrator
i was like well i'm glad i still had you
along for the ride and some people have
just put it down like i can't take this
guy i can't take this tech bro
interesting um but um but i
love
unlikable
narrators um i love
you know
like problematic because we're all
problematic we're all unlikable and i
and like so i want like in the same way
that like ignatius riley in confederacy
of dances is kind of like this
reactionary in cell you know um and who
just farts and burps all the time or the
the the guy in frederick xle's uh
um a fan's notes is like this
self-sabotaging [ __ ] um or um that
note some underground
the guy yeah
he's like the original one right um
these are the most compelling uh kind of
characters for me um and
they have confessions to make and they
have depths because you realize they're
giving you their worst self they're
they're not trying to pretty it up and
there's no uplift in it
in any of these yeah it's it's not going
to uplift you and you're not going to
feel better about humanity afterwards
but i think you're going to feel a
little bit of truth and so
like there are like things that have
happened in my life that i have taken
and mined for
um
for material
yeah i have gone to those camps you know
i i have you know
had you know relationships in which like
some of these things have happened um
but um
but the guy is
definitely
not me and i would not want to be him
but i he's the kind of person that i
would like to know yeah um and i and i
like spending time with this person um
he's a lot smarter than me number one
and he and i love fools and he does not
suffer fool's glasses yeah and i love a
fool
um i love like giving people rope and
letting them talk um and and i think
every novelist should and um the uh yeah
the um so so yeah obviously and every
novelist takes from their own real life
you know um i'm sure you know
c.s lewis
you know realized that he was a a little
jerk and put that into edmond you know
in the chronicles of narnia it's always
a character that character right that's
the yeah a real prig you know or eustis
uh uh used to scrub yeah there was once
a boy named used to scrub and he almost
deserved it and i suppose somebody whose
name was clive lewis
you know would probably
uh groove on that um but it yeah it's
it's so it's a ones which like because
so much of culture is so smooth now it
goes down so smooth and they ca
and i co-host a podcast called secrets
of story with this kind of story guru
named matt bird and he talks about okay
how do we make our main character
likable how do we make them compelling
what are they how do we make the
audience leave karen invest on them and
like there's so many ways to make things
smooth and agreeable and go down easy
but
and even though it might repel or pulse
you at first
and maybe it you might even put the book
down i want something that's going to
have sharp edges that's going to catch
and so it's going to catch in your
throat on the way down and when you
swallow it it might tear up your throat
a little bit on the way down but you'll
remember that you swallowed it yeah um
it's in uh and so yeah but that's not
it's not for everybody it's i mean it
seems like the main character he's
looking back on these things and he does
have enough humility to be able to say
oh wow that was really and now you know
we don't we don't
have this term back then when we were
young but it's very common now that what
cringy stuff that is right i like that
that term because it does convey
something
and he's not like you know the
realized sage who's looking back on this
stuff as oh i've gotten completely
beyond this because you know when he
engages with julia he's still kind of a
hot mess
[Laughter]
i love hot messes yeah they're great to
write about they're fun to read i don't
know what's wrong with people that they
don't want to read about hot messes well
you brought up that term truth earlier
and so
is there a kind of truthfulness
that
characters who aren't so as you're
putting it like polished
can reveal to us you can see through
these these cracks
uh whereas
a good
i think if if somebody
is telling you something that makes them
look bad they're probably telling me
unless
they're telling you the bad thing to
avoid the even bigger bad thing like the
guy who killed somebody i i saw this in
a show once i forget exactly what it was
i think it was a cartoon where somebody
had killed somebody and then his wife
you know like walks in while he's on his
computer and she's like what are you
doing and he's like watching porn you
know because he knows that that's going
to get him in less trouble than like
tracking down how to dissolve a body an
acid or something like that
i mean i'll also i mean
yeah yeah i mean like say like
what's the quote by wickenshine if
somebody has done like gone to the worst
places i can't judge him but if he tells
me that he did it you know i in the
service of and because he's got great
virtue uh then i know he is a fraud
something like that
what's a quote you must go i don't know
it but that that um i mean that's a
great idea that
it's the motivation that when the person
starts talking about that if you're
confessing and you're like oh wow i'm i
really screwed up you know i did this
terrible thing and i don't actually have
any excuses for it that's one thing when
you're like yes i did it for saving
mankind now you know there's something
something really hinky going on there
right
yeah exactly um so
he doesn't try to justify himself and
and or like if he tries to like he
almost immediately says look i know i'm
trying to justify myself here um so i
and i hopefully that will make people
like think well i might not like him but
i know he's telling the truth and i
might not like him but i trust him um
and uh i think it and um
yeah well that you know that brings up
something that when we we met i asked
you about you know when i looked before
i read the book
for
people who had something to say about it
a lot of people talked about an
unreliable narrator and then you know so
i was like kind of looking for that as i
was reading the book and i was like well
there's no unreliable narrator here at
all i'm not seeing any of that like well
i say on this page this happened and
then i call it into question
and in a way you've you've got the
opposite of that a narrator who is
perfectly willing to
you know if we're going to talk
dostoevsky's underground manual rip his
chest open and show you everything
um how the hell do you think people
wound up thinking that you have an
unreliable narrator
i think i know why because it gets more
and more fantastical and hallucinatory
as it goes on okay i myself take those
hallucinations seriously as a kind of
reality that he's experiencing that the
world itself is actually going a little
bit crazy and he's having visions that
reveal a reality i think you're saying
oh this guy is going crazy and so
therefore he's becoming unreliable in
the way that he's reporting the world
and this is because um
this book
like it did really well in england like
i noticed but it like it was like like
like the the times of london said oh
it's one of the best science fiction
books of the year or like the guardian
gave it a good review financial times
gave it a good review but in america it
went almost entirely unremarked upon and
unreviewed upon and then people who were
reviewing it were like getting it wrong
and i think and i mentioned this to you
when i when we were talking and i'm just
gonna say the same thing again yeah
americans are immune to uh metaphysical
stories they don't like them they like
repertorial journalistic stories yeah um
and and you know like so
it's only from
uh um
england do you have things like
narnia yeah or lord of the rings these
kind of visionary things and when they
come out of america like you you'll
you'll have somebody who's truly
visionary but like ursula le guin but
she is a you know a
a marginal figure in some ways even
though she's usually like
influential but like the the things that
like really
take off for americans are things that
are just journalistic and repertorial
and even if it's set in another land
like
the game of thrones
it's not it's not doesn't have a true
metaphysics to it it doesn't like
game of thrones is like hey remember
lord of the rings yeah i loved it
there's there's magic and there's
hobbits and there's elves yeah what if
we got rid of all
what else is there well well there's men
right
what if we got rid of the magic the
elves the hobbits
and the metaphysics and just had the men
okay
yeah i think and maybe that's why i went
so well over because americans are
don't like metaphysical stories yeah and
and i think why is that i was like oh
it's not because americans are have less
imagination it's because this is a very
metaphysical country it's founded on a
document of ideas everything is soaked
in
like sometimes the most absurd kind of
christianity so when an american
is try somebody tries to give them a
visionary or a metaphysical story
they're like uh i gave at the office
like i
have to deal with people saying crazy
metaphysical things to me all this yeah
it's sort of like russians love like bad
metaphysics drives good metaphysics out
then right
gresham's law i haven't heard of this oh
it has to do with currency well with
with money in general uh if you've got
counterfeit money circulating around
pretty soon nobody knows what what's
real money and not so they become very
leery about taking it so
the people who know that they have good
money they hold on to it
and
it goes out of circulation so pretty
soon
and you can do this with ideas you can
do this with whatever you like pretty
soon it's all the air zots all the fake
all the the crappy stuff that's
circulating around that people are
willing to allow to circulate you know
so this sounds like the kind of theory
that like uh like
keynes would have like solved like
exactly
the percentage at which yeah
and then how do you fix it you know how
do you go to get an influx of reliable
stuff in you know um and it's a lot
easier i think to do that with money
than it is with ideas because ideas are
you know they're not directly comparable
with each other right
well yeah and that's why i mean like uh
it's a dark genius when stephen bannon
was like saying yeah
the way we're going to get our way is
just in the realm of ideas if you're
just going to his quote flood the zone
with [ __ ] right
you know and so then the point isn't to
get
the other side to be persuaded by
arguments the point is to bring the
whole idea of truth itself
into
to make people just make people throw up
their hands like i don't even know and
so and so you just say oh i guess it's
just politics both sides have this point
of view or just like well i guess since
everything is so unknowable i can just
kind of choose what i want to believe it
doesn't matter yeah right
um and so and i mean this is a technique
i think of you know of
in
of propaganda like yeah it's not
necessarily
to to convince somebody it's to simply
make truth itself
uh like a non-operative concept exactly
yeah to take it out of uh circulation to
go back to that that metaphor
um
one of the other things i wanted to ask
you about that you did bring up when you
were on your your book tour
so the character um in this story
because of the peculiarity of the kind
of work that he does and we should we
should talk about that a little bit you
mentioned that he can predict when
people are going to die but it has to do
with these particles called thanatons uh
which you know have have a role in that
and the more that you do these
calculations the less you can handle
being involved with computers because
they do calculations too but the
calculations create a kind of
i don't know what to call it like
interference or static or bad noise
almost like tinnitus yeah
so yes you mentioned that
something kind of similar to that
happened to you but not not exactly the
same as the character so
yes
that seems like a pretty bad impediment
to have in a technological age as
everything becomes more and more digital
based
yeah
well so yeah i mean this all came out of
like
th there's a like i stopped computer
programming because i just like disliked
it like so the thing that brought me so
much joy i didn't like it anymore um and
the um and it's not like you know
obviously i can deal with computers i'm
on one right now exactly but like but
they we all do feel a little bit creeped
out you know by computers in a way that
we didn't 10 years ago and i wanted to
track that like emotion that we all are
starting to feel and my friend matt bird
who i do the podcast with i disagree
with him on a lot of things but he did
say something i agree with very much and
i might have said this in milwaukee as
well that like realistic fiction is how
it is genre fiction is how it feels
and and so in genre of fiction like you
know
i don't know like okay realistic fiction
about a bad prom would just like show
you something it's just like literary
would just show like oh here are all
like the little bad things that could go
wrong in a problem a genre thing would
be carrying yeah right
you know it's like but that's how it
feels it feels like the bucket of blood
is going over your head and only genre
fiction can really get put across the
feeling that world-ending feeling so
like you could write a realistic fiction
about going to school for the first time
where you don't know anybody and kind of
get some of it but you people kids only
really felt it with harry potter when it
was genres like oh no like you know it's
it's like so everything is so heightened
and therefore it matches the level it is
in your mind you you know um and so um
like i even in the book um there is this
kind of mathematics like i didn't want
to have the kind though when you learned
the time of your death to be learning it
from an app okay like that would be the
most boring way to do it and um and so i
was like well what's the way to do it
well this is an opportunity to do
something weird and interesting and and
to make up a kind of new mathematics a
new kind of physics
and like i so i invented this kind of
mathematics that can't be done by a
computer so it's called subjective
mathematics and so when
and that's how that's the only way you
can to kind of converse with these
phantoms and find out when somebody's
death is but it's kind of like pulling
the sticks of the i ching or something
what it is is like you you get down with
a person you have all these books of
reference and then you say a nonsense
phrase to them
the subject you want to learn how when
they're going to die they say the first
thing that comes into their head you
have to
search through all your books and say
the next necessary nonsense phrase you
kind of go back and forth and it's like
an interview but it just sounds like
nonsense poetry going back and forth but
i wanted it to be like um you know in
blade runner in into android stream of
electric sheep that interview you know
in which you know you see a
tortoise in the desert yeah the voight
comp test yes i wanted to be something
like that in that tradition so yeah
philip k dick again um and um
and but then like when you do this kind
of
math this kind of subjective math you
feel the math of others
and in particular computers just do math
in a way that's brutal and
stabbing and primitive and it kind of
drives you yeah it's just brutal force
right as something yeah exactly there's
no art in it yeah yeah and so in that
and so when he walks through a room with
computers like he he feels kind of like
a static around a kind of glitchiness
around him that he can kind of muscle
through but he feels it and any and some
people have to quit this job because it
just over overwhelms them um but uh i
wanted to have uh something like that
that gives that queasness that we feel
because genre is how it feels not how it
is okay
you know the the idea of the subjective
mathematics which is subjective not just
like
it has to do with humans but like each
person as you say has to like come up
with their own
their own visualization their own
interpretation of it one of the things i
was reminded of is um
the
stories and i don't i think i want to
say um the the main character's name is
shea in it that fletcher pratt and elle
sprague decamp
wrote where you get into these alternate
universes by using
uh symbolic logic
and now you know as as a you know
math philosophy major i did a lot of
work in in that as a undergraduate and
you and you know
perfectly well that you can't like
rearrange the axioms
of a proof to somehow put yourself in a
different world but they managed to make
it narratively convincing that these
researchers could somehow
like you know get you from this world
into the world of um
well the first one is the world of norse
mythology and they have adventures and
stuff like that and i forget exactly how
they get back
but
there's the we arrange some more yeah
there's like there's a couple different
worlds that they they do this with and
um that sounds great
i was thinking that the sim you know the
subjective mathematics is kind of like
that it's a
it's a way of our conceptualizing
what you know
mathematics or logic or we could take
other formal systems like what music
could possibly do that doesn't do in our
reality but could do
in a fictional
reality um and so i thought that what
you invented there kind of fits into
i don't know like a
the pantheon is the wrong word because
that has to do with like you know
authors and stuff like that but like um
a toolbox
although that's a little bit too prosaic
um
these interesting ways in which authors
have
taken
formal systems
and turn them into something that would
like reveal a different reality because
because the subjective mathematics is
revealing reality right it's telling you
yeah when you're gonna die and and
potentially
you know other things as well
yeah and it also i mean when you were
talking about rearranging symbols to
change reality that kind of happens in
dare to know as well because
like i have this whole subplot about
like i mean it's not even a subplot this
is just straight up history like the
history of science is really kind of
found up in history of the upcoming it's
crazy stuff
yeah so so you know uh kepler you know
his mom was you know nearly burned for
witchcraft and he like you know he he he
told he astrology he did astrology uh um
like uh the um
you know heisenberg no
not heisenberg paulie was really into
the occult wolfgang paulie um the guy
who was the founder of the jet
propulsion laboratory um you know was a
full-blown satanist and did sex magic
with alistair crowley um like newton
famously 90 of his writings as keynes as
we mentioned before
pointed out was 90 percent of his
readings were about biblical alchemy and
sacred geometry and things like that and
um and so i kind of made the series like
well what if you know every time there
is a paradigm shift like in the thomas
[ __ ] sense
of scientific revolutions
whatever it's it's it's accompanied by
this kind of burst of kind of
supernatural occult static okay um and
but and it's necessary because
and this is kind of like a
throwaway riff later on in the book and
i don't expect everybody it's kind of
like one of the goofiest things i put in
the book but like what if like when
somebody
you know when plunk is inventing quantum
mechanics he's not just discovering it
but like with this burst of supernatural
energy he's changing the laws of the
universe which reverberates forwards and
backwards through time and it what was a
newtonian universe becomes a quantum
universe um and i and i got that idea
from like reading
reading kuhn because i remember like our
teachers saying look every time there's
a paradigm shift like
you might have mass in the concept of
mass in the
newtonian universe that that's that
concept of mass even though it's the
same name and has some of the same
functions is totally different in the
post newton universe and so it's like
really it does the whole universe
changes into what i thought like what if
it truly does change not just in our
minds but it reverberates backwards and
forwards your time and the whole
structure universe changes when we make
a certain
judgment about it that also is in the
only way that that judgment can happen
it's like do a genius
like being at the foot of this material
and kind of really struggling with it
and then this burst of supernatural like
occult energy well in the thanatons
right they come into existence at a
particular
time or date we could say they're not
they're not there in the universe
all by themselves as we find out in
the the course of the story
yeah they seem to be like something
that's generated by humans and that they
human like for the universe to keep on
persisting like they have to be
refreshed every once in a while by this
gigantic human sacrifice and there's
like a gigantic human sacrifice every
thousand years or so the last time it
happened was a thousand years ago in
cahokia um which we haven't even gotten
to kahoot yet
and now it's happening i mean i think a
lot of people
in the midwest still don't know that
like this was i mean not here in
milwaukee obviously although you know uh
just down where you are in chicago
massive nexus of a trading network that
was incredibly complex the cahokia seems
to have been
even more complex it was an entire
society and
yeah you know so like before for those
who haven't heard of it like any like
before any european set foot in america
like there was this
conflict there was this urban native
american society that we don't even know
the name of it uh we the the when it was
found just like the native american
tribe that happened to be there was
called the cahokians and so they just
named it after that so we'll call it
cahokia
um but they um
it was a city that was about 20 000 30
000 people it was bigger than london or
paris at the time it was right outside
what is now um
st louis and it was only really
discovered when they were like digging
up highways
in the eisenhower administration and
they found all this stuff and they
people have been finding arrowheads
there for years but like there are all
these mounds these massive mounds that a
lot of them just got bulldozed to put up
tract housing and stuff like that um but
one of them that they couldn't do that
was this 100 foot tall mound monk's
mound which is like the center of this
place and so now the place has been
declared like a unesco heritage site um
and all the the st they've tried to
restore it as much as they can but it's
just a bunch of mounds now but it was
like like as proud a place as like the
aztecs
you know or whatever but it's totally
unknown i didn't learn about it until my
30s um and this is erasure of you know
pre-columbian history in america is
you know a crime intellectually um and
and socially and it's something that we
should know about and um
but one thing that was happening there
was these massive human sacrifices and
we see that like it's it kind of started
in about
cokia started around like it was a bunch
of
more or less disconnected communities
until about 10 50.
and then at 10 50 something changed it
became this very urban society that went
to about 1350. interestingly at around
1050 there was this great
the nebula and uh there's a supernova in
the sky which is now just a crab nebula
but like all over the world people say
oh my god there's this new star in the
sky that was like as bright as the moon
um and huge and but that was the time
that cahokia
became cahokia and so i kind of worked
that into the plot as well this kind of
like we have things going on in the sky
we have things going on down below we
have like we have
civilizations going through cycles just
like ours is going through a cycle
everybody thinks that the way that
things things are are going to last
forever but it feels right now that
things are changing really fast
in a way that like kind of like the long
kind of
like it was kind of this feeling like oh
yeah world war ii stopped and like that
was more or less the end of history the
kind of fukuyama kind of thing and now
we're just going to clean up uh the the
little the ends but of course you know
whenever somebody says that that's when
things are about to change at the end of
the 19th century people are saying oh
yeah science is over we just got to
clean up all progress
yeah yeah and um but no
it's just like quantum mechanics is it's
all about discontinuous jumps and
unexpected changes and we're in the
middle of it right now i'm sure the
cahokians thought that cahokia would
have gone on forever too and we don't
even remember them yeah um and it was
so and and they the calhouns were around
longer than the united states was
um they lasted for about 400 years
i guess we'll see them at the finish
line we'll see how much longer we
survive
yeah i'm not i'm not particularly
optimistic about uh the society that
that we're in for for a number of
reasons i do have i i want to be
cognizant of your time but i do have one
kind of interesting uh question that has
to do with you could call it the
practice of
authorship but not the writing part so
you know we met on while you were doing
this this book tour and you've got a
book that's about a guy who's a salesman
for a very unique product right
the book is obviously a product that you
have produced which contains this other
you know imaginary product so when
you're on a book tour are you like
selling books are you selling the story
are you a salesman of sorts yes okay i
mean why else i mean like it's like
the thing is i'm not a good salesman
like like i
i always just like
well i always disliked selling things
even as a kid like
it's embarrassing to ask some others for
something yeah to tout yourself like if
it feels like you're putting yourself
like it goes against everything your
midwestern self tells you to be like you
know yeah um even as a kid i hated going
door to door to sell things you know
like for boy scouts or school
fundraisers chocolates
pizzas yeah all that yeah exactly do you
remember it's a baby you remember the
walker yeah what
yeah stuff like that like i mean the
badger your aunt like hey i'm gonna walk
so give me money for every mile i walk
like they get they're just doing you a
favor and uh so maybe for that very
reason i'm interested in the kind of
person for whom selling comes naturally
or it's a vocation for them they're good
at it yeah and that's part of where the
idea of the book comes from like for a
long time i wanted to write a novel
about a salesman but i wanted to be a
science fiction story which is a
salesman kind of has some esoteric
technical expertise he's selling that i
don't know what the product would be but
i want to be an odd speculative thing we
don't have in our world but yeah the
whole point of a book tour is to sell
books to get people excited about your
book and to accomplish that you have to
be a bit of a salesman you have to be a
bit of a showman maybe you even have to
be a bit of a ham you know you have to
um and uh
it's generous that you called it a book
tour because i just drove up from
chicago and then i drove back yeah so
if we can call that a tour yeah
the sense that that's the way things are
heading these days you don't you're not
like staying in a hotel here in a hotel
there i mean maybe if you write some
book that's massive amounts of sellers
yeah but i think for a lot of um authors
who have
interesting work that's a bit more you
know stuck in in a niche and maybe maybe
science fiction is these days kind of a
niche stuck in a niche let's say
flourishing yeah there you go yeah yeah
well i mean and it's it's a very well
populated one
um
maybe that's how it goes may and
especially now
that um you know we've had covid so
people became nervous about traveling
and we've got all these ways of
connecting
on the internet maybe
maybe it shifts you know you're not like
taking the locomotive to the next
whistle stop or something like that yeah
well i mean i learned with my first book
that you have to hustle okay and and
like you i mean
and the publicity people for dare to
know are great but like it's expected
that you have to hustle and i if my
first book which is a young adult novel
like i could get booked at schools right
there i have like
a a
you get paid to do it and you have a
captive audience you don't have to worry
that only 10 people are going to come to
the bookstore you have like 400 kids in
a room and then you become a showman a
little bit yeah and you put on a show
and you get them all excited for your
book and um
and that's how you sell them um and so i
was like kind of like just book it and
so
between that and so i run a film
festival uh for kids called the 90
second newbery film festival everything
is for like 11 years which kids make
short movies that tell the entire
stories of newberry winning books in
about 90 seconds and then we it screens
all over the country like at its height
before cove it was like in 14 cities
we're building it up now after two years
of virtual screenings but um yeah that's
involved being a showman in that each of
these shows i would do a bunch of school
visits leading up to it which i'm
selling my book and then i'm selling my
book at the theater or at the library or
wherever we're putting it on and so i
was continually on tour
and i think that's the only reason why
my y.a book which
i think as hume said of her his first
book fell stillborn from the press
like uh uh i think that that i think
it's uh um
that's uh that's the only way it's still
in print is because i hustled so hard
for it um and um
and actually one of the things i did is
um the book that won that year
mine came out was neil gaiman he won for
the graveyard book a famous fantasy
british fantasy author neil gaiman and i
kind of like wrote these ridiculous
short story online about how neil gaiman
i deserve the newbery and not neil
gaiman
and and
and then like he found out about it and
then he linked to it which sent a
million of his followers over to me and
they a lot of them bought my book and
then at the american library association
conference
uh i had a friend in the audience
dressed up as neil gaiman and i tackled
him and stole the newbery from him
and then all the librarians like gasping
like what's going on and then i uh and
then like another friend came in just as
the head of the american library
association and put us through a series
of mental and physical tests to see who
truly deserves the new barriers we did
like a thumb war we did like fencing we
did tag team wrestling ran around the
room but then i lost all of these things
to neil gaim fake neil gaiman they put
me on her altar and sacrificed me to the
dark gods of the ala uh using a knife
forged in the very burning of the
library of alexandria um and um but then
i
but but then i after i died the fake
neil gaiman led all the librarians and
chanting give kennedy the newberry until
i sprang back to life and accepted the
new barrier from him well neil gaiman
found out about that too and linked to
that and so then when he actually came
to chicago like the um
that uh to speak at the university of
chicago one of the organizers knew about
i said oh why don't we have you open for
neil gaiman and so then i got to meet
him and i got to do this whole like
speech before he went on and i kind of
opened for him saying like oh you know
neil gaiman and i grew up together in
saginaw michigan we were best friends
you know but then you know and and i
made up this whole more lies and i
realized oh the way that you kind of
hustle is by irritating the mighty you
you have to like pick some kind of enemy
and kind of like who's above you and
kind of like joke at them in a way that
they would like they kind of like bring
you up to their level a little bit and
br and kind of pivot their community
towards you yeah um and so you find a
million ways like i did a similar thing
with lemony snicket uh daniel handler
the guy with the series of unfortunate
events books
um and i yeah i i'll
irritate the mighty is my look
is my winning strategy as it turns out
is it a winning strategy is it a winning
strategy i suppose it depends on what
you have to sacrifice along the way
right i mean the way that you're doing
it was kind of kind of funny and all
that but you could imagine somebody who
doesn't quite get how to do it and
they're like well what i need to do is
just say terrible things about the
mighty
audrey niffnegger who wrote the time
traveler's wife um there was a
a benefit an auction for the evanston
public library in which they're like oh
um
we you know one of the things that we're
auctioning off is an evening with audrey
niffenegger that she had generously
donated like oh meet me at this fancy
place downtown the russian uh
kind of like this russian tea room kind
of place
and uh and like 10 people can bid on it
and spend a night like discussing
literature with her and so i also
submitted for the auction an evening
with audrey niffenegger with me dressed
as audrey fake audrey niffenegger um and
i and i said look i i would go to this
nice place downtown but have you seen
the prices there i'm going to take you
to this ice cream place around the
corner from my house
and um and and there's pictures of me
kind of dressed up as much as i can as
audrey niffenegger and the people who
bid on it thought they were getting
audrey and if anger and they showed up
the place one of them turned around and
walked out the other one just tolerated
me pretending to be audrey niffenegger
the whole night and but she found out
about later and she was like
what is he doing
why is he mocking a poor old woman like
me i was like first you're not poor yeah
um and so you're not that old
you know um you know go along with it
and um and i i ran into her at my local
bookstore and we said like she saw me i
saw her and we both just kind of
slowly stepped away from each other
um and uh um yeah i don't i don't think
she liked the gym so yeah it can
backfire
yeah well that's that's interesting i
mean nobody nobody's a hundred percent
when they're selling anyway so hustling
i suppose yeah
as well you know
well sure i think these are stunts that
i wouldn't have tried i won't try now
okay put it that way i think this is
what they call problematic behavior now
i think this is more in the wild and
woolly uh uh late aughts early teens of
this century i think things have gotten
more clamped down uh um i i think of my
my little my little scapes and japes
would no longer be appreciated
no putting on the gesture outfit or
anything these days right no no no oh no
i gotta have gravitas now i write for
adults
well that's true so this is this is a
good place to bring things to a close um
once again everybody who's watching or
listening dare to know really great
uh new science fiction novel you should
check it out um i'll let you have
whatever last word you'd like to have um
sure um i mean also check out my book
for young adults called the order of odd
fish it's really funny and good um and
um it's um and the 92nd newberry film
festival at
ninezeronewberry1r.com 90 newbury.com if
you have kids uh you know if you want to
make a 90-second movie of charlotte's
web or whatever and submit it like we're
taking submissions they're due in
january and it's a lot of fun and the
people put their weird twist on it so
like it's like people do charlotte's web
but in the style of a horror movie you
know or it's like stop-motion legos you
know or as a musical like and people do
all kinds of crazy and fun things it's a
lot of fun and um in my next book uh
bride of the tornado comes out next year
so uh yeah so we'll have to have you on
again you haven't you know yes please
yeah well thanks so much james kennedy
for coming on uh what is actually thank
you greg first special edition of worlds
of speculative fiction
and uh it's great to great to chat with
you
hey great to chat with you too
you